well in health care most of the people
are talking about how do we take a
system that really focuses on just
treating people after they're sick and
injured or have some type of disease and
completely transforming it into a system
that focuses on wellness to really build
a health care system that's a well care
system not just a sick care system and
making that transformation while
Sutton's perhaps easy to do is not all
the financial incentives in the system
work against building a well system the
the delivery system is not there to
really provide the infrastructure for
wellness and health insurance benefits
in particular are not designed to
promote it so a simple concept but it is
fundamental but going from A to B to do
that is going to take a lot of work how
to really focus on for reforms one is
we've got to get the cost of healthcare
down and one way to do that is really
focusing on this explosion of obesity in
the country among kids adolescents and
adults about thirty percent of the
growth and health care spending over the
last twenty years is due to the doubling
of obesity and so we have to find ways
to prevent the rise in childhood obesity
obesity among adults and seniors have
these are going to attack this in
multiple settings schools communities at
the workplace and how we structure
incentives in health insurance so that
be the first area second is that about
three-quarters of what we spend on
health care is linked to people with
chronic disease diabetes high blood
pressure bad cholesterol a pulmonary
disease arthritis asthma and you can go
down the list we don't do a good job of
working with patients to help them
manage those conditions and we have a
lot of bad statistics approved the point
in the Medicare program twenty percent
of people who go into the hospital are
readmitted into the hospital within 30
days that's just an artifact that we
don't have a management system working
with patients outside of a physician's
office at the hospital so part two is
that we really need to build
a delivery system infrastructure that
allows us to work with patients largely
through primary care and nurse
practitioners to do a better job of
managing chronic illness the third thing
I'd focus on is reducing the
administrative cost of our healthcare
system it's too complicated there's too
much paper it costs too much money to
administer this is a problem for
physicians hospitals and patients so if
we can find a way to streamline the
system to make it simpler physicians can
spend more time with their patients
doing clinical work and less time
filling out forms that really don't add
much in terms of value to health care in
the system and finally we've got to find
a way to cover everybody we have 47
million Americans who don't have health
insurance in this country it is a
politically a difficult issue to figure
out the Congress is debating this right
now and the tough thing about it is to
figure out how do you pay for it and who
pays for it I'm hoping that this time
around we can come to some consensus on
this we tried this 15 years ago and it
ended in a stalemate nothing happens and
the dilemma is all the problems have
gotten worse over the past 15 years
costs are escalating we have more and
more uninsured and so on so I'm hoping
that everybody recognizes this time that
we need to compromise everybody's got to
give up something nobody's going to get
their first choice the second choice
can't be the status quo it's got to
really be a recognition that to solve
this problem we're really going to have
to work collectively together to do it I
am I would give it a seventy five eighty
percent chance and for several reasons
that the main protagonists that really
scuttled health care reform last time
the pharmaceutical industry the health
insurers the drug and device
manufacturers all of them have come
together to work with the White House
including the hospitals and the
physicians and basically come out and
supported a universal coverage proposal
that would require all Americans to have
health insurance that's revolutionary
that is a major sea change in terms of
where we were compared to 15 years ago
the second part of it is that I think
everybody understands in the
Congress what a key priority this issue
is to Senator Kennedy and we all know
that Senator Kennedy is suffering from a
very bad form of cancer but this is a
man that is active in the debate it
would be his lifetime work to get health
care coverage for all Americans he's
made it his main goal in the United
States Congress for several decades now
and he has devoted to getting this
passed so I think those two issues
combined with the the focus that the
President Obama has on the issue he said
that this is his major domestic priority
so I think there's going to find a way
to get this done it may be messy it may
not be what everybody wants to have
completed in one swoop but I think we'll
pass something very substantial
hopefully by the end of this year i
think the european models have the most
relevance because they have a great
focus on primary care we don't have a
focus on primary care in this country we
have a focus on tertiary very
sophisticated care the way the european
countries built their healthcare systems
as they started from the bottom up
primary care and then moving towards the
top until they ran out of money so
they've got a tremendous primary care
infrastructure they have all the
technological tools we have is just that
they don't have them in every hospital
in those countries we did it just the
opposite and we started from the top
down I have a very technologically
sophisticated healthcare system but no
primary care infrastructure and the
problem that that faces is that our
health care measures infant mortality
rates longevity just basic public health
measures are nowhere near as good as the
European countries despite the fact that
we spend twice as much per person on
health care in this country than the
Europeans do so I think there's a lot to
learn about how do you build a primary
care infrastructure that really focuses
on primary prevention preventing disease
and really keeping people healthy well
the first place to start i think is a
medicare program that that is a program
that spends about four hundred billion
dollars a year and it is really not
designed to effectively keep people
healthy and so one of the low-hanging
for
oops is how do you build prevention into
that program how do we do a better job
of working with patients who are seniors
to keep them out of the hospital and out
of the physician's office and a lot of
that is just common sense work with
nurse practitioners working with
patients at home social workers helping
patients out with other types of
healthcare needs now this isn't a thing
that we could do very quickly we could
do a very inexpensively and there's
bipartisan support to do it so my sense
is on health care reform is that we need
to start places where there's mutual
agreement we can build bipartisan
support it's just common sense to build
a capacity to work with patients once
they lead the physician's office
ironically that doesn't happen today you
have a 80 year old woman with diabetes
and high blood pressure and bad
cholesterol and back problems and they
get a care plan from their physician
they go home and really you're on your
own there's really no a benefit out
there to to help you maintain and
monitor what's going on so we need to
fix that and I think that's an area that
we could do very quickly well first of
all we got to you know recognize it as a
priority you know we spend less than
three percent of our healthcare dollar
on prevention everything else is on
treatment the irony is is that we will
not pay for somebody to exercise or you
know stay on the right diet or have
their blood pressure checked but if you
don't take care of yourself and you
don't monitor your blood pressure levels
and blood sugar levels and you get
something happen with your legs and you
get an amputation will pay for that and
with diabetes is a great example like
diabetic amputations of the number two
source of amputations in this country
most of it's preventable but we won't
pay for it so we've got to switch things
around we've gotta pay for prevention in
how we design health insurance we have
to find ways to pay for prevention at
the workplace to try to work with the
employees that want to change their
behavior we give them the tools to do it
we've got to build it into schools we
don't teach this anymore in terms of
just basic nutrition
diet and exercise has been replaced and
crowded out by a variety of other
initiatives so if we don't start it with
the schools by the time they get out of
school that we've already lost 10 15
years so we have to make it a priority
and we have to fund it and we need to
fund it in a variety of settings schools
the communities workplace and we need to
change the whole structure of how we do
health insurance to really focus on
paying for prevention and paying for
wellness and not just focusing on paying
for things that happen if we don't take
care of ourselves I think that you know
the industries like the pharmaceutical
industry and the hospital industry and
the drug and device industry have a role
to play but I don't think it can be
unfettered certainly if they come in and
play an educational role about new drugs
new innovations that are appropriately I
think counter balanced in terms of the
pros and cons by others who really
understand what the trade-offs are then
I think that that's a positive way to go
i think that the problem is is that
oftentimes you get money involved in
this in terms of incentives for making
prescriptions and incentives for using
particular types of drugs and those
types of things are problematic but
purely in an educational standpoint to
provide information as long as its
proprietary balance whether the pros and
cons what are the other treatment
options what does it cost what are the
improvements and health care outcomes
expected with it information is good and
I think that we should you know welcome
the industry to come in to do it but
it's got to be done I think in a broader
context of what are the pros and cons of
different ways of treating patients